on méconnaît soubiane des noms
accéder faire elle m'a tomates choux des
lécheurs délit qui
se suivent et sa beauté
andré flajolet soit 1 devant l'émoi
et vous entrez doubler la cadence
mais toi les gens
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez voir un truc cool
non l'astuce est merveilleux rend très
bien chez vous ennuie
j'étais toujours là d'accord vous ne
prêtez dernier celle là s'appelle la
régente émergents
[Musique]
mauvaise nouvelle tu es mort
docteur payet this will les chapeauter
g9 vie bon et tuez moi combien de fois
déjà
les maths et morne défraîchi on a ses
mérites je vous offre une cache pas
qu'il ya des fluides et même la tête à
un char attendent toujours le sien cette
régate et
[Musique]
regardez regardez
là tout à l'heure il ya eu les géants
alors ça fait combien tout ça 4 ça nous
met à 8 poté que veux tu fermes ta
d'énergie quand il n'a qu'une vie à
vivre c'est ce qui la rend unique
volpé rang
un mois se déplacent pas
bon j'adore les trois autres femmes il
tait mafieux est censé être mort le chat
la radio mais chaque fois qu'on fait
tout ça part en vrille et moi confié
obligé papa plus sérieux qui trouvent ça
maignien
il a vu qu'il peut pas durer
[Musique]
we
are est que vas tu voulais un oeil